so you guys might have heard about this
little nutty law in Arizona it is
sb-1062 and this has passed the Arizona
Legislature and this allows businesses
as long as they assert their religious
beliefs to refuse service to customers
and now basically this means if you're
gay and they don't like you they don't
have to serve you so just real quick on
this thing because Jan Brewer may veto
this thing by the time we finish this
conversation she may not be TOEIC she
tweeted last night that she's gonna do
what's best for Arizona I don't know
what the hell that means
what is going on in Arizona what is
happening in that kooky state you're
trying to eliminate the illegal alien
gay people from going alien that's a lot
of Republican buzzwords and one thing
that you think that what they're doing
is they're cutting out some of their
business yeah it's ridiculous on every
level
yeah Republicans they love business
isn't this just the stupidest thing
possible wouldn't you want business they
love money it's this amazing place to be
caught between these two conflicting
fetishes of like business success and
and hey in hating certain individual III
think that uh I'm behind anything that
makes sure that gay people don't get
certain kinds of chicken sandwiches yeah
I just don't think they're like you know
John's chicken sandwich should ever
serve a gay person yeah you don't want
those fried chicken sandwiches actually
a huge opportunity to put weird stuff in
people sandwiches you know like you know
if you why don't you let them in allow
them to order and just do weird stuff to
their food yeah that's your American
right I say it is should we give a
little not be so glib about what the
religious people want you know what I
mean the Christian Right says they're
under attack and if they have a
religious belief that they don't want to
serve gay people because they're in
senshu we have any respect for that in
2014 no and I think we're gonna put
Brett's picture up on the wall of these
establishments oh no it's the other way
around yeah
great I'm not following you know because
the Abbi oh I'm mixing up the to storm
you know what I'm gonna go with you so
the Abbi I'll talk to the camera for a
second so the a B which is basically the
most famous gay bar in the United States
certainly in California it is right in
West Hollywood right where I live they
have announced that they are going to
ban people who back
this legislation legislators who back
this legislation we have a quote from
the founder of the abbey this is from
Dave Cooley who owns the abbey he says I
want to send a message to all those
people out there who can play Christian
values with discrimination we don't want
your kind here I've learned that I can't
stop crazy ignorant or stupid but I can
stop it from coming through my doors and
he's literally going to show mug shots
of these legislators not that these
people are going to show up at the Abbey
would they well rich head shot obviously
will be there you never know because it
seems like the most homophobic or the
most hypocritical yeah so so you think
they might be showing up there in drag
perhaps or toe-tapping
or something I don't know I just think
it's so funny that anybody would
discriminate from getting any kind of
business yeah I don't understand that
and in this economy yeah yeah I think
this is a huge opportunity
I think they should leave the photos up
so we know the names and faces of the
anti-gay legislators but if they're
coming to the Abbey
I think you should let them in let them
get a few in them maybe have some drinks
yeah and then take some photos yeah of
them and you know yeah and then before
after you know I'm just saying like if
they're coming to the Abbey and they're
an anti-gay Jat legislator don't you
want photo evidence of them being in
your establishment right and enjoying
you know you know a little sailor Jerry
maybe it may be a rum and coke ya know
and obviously the owners being he's
being a little tongue-in-cheek because
these people most likely aren't showing
up there but is there a risk in gays
becoming as sort of intolerant of
different views as the Christian Right
that we're always fighting against you
know what I mean if no both times I like
it yeah
no I mean you're attacking somebody's
human right to exclude them from going
into any place so no you know except for
me like I there's some part of me that
says hey you get you know what if
there's a gay established gay right
establishment that doesn't want anti-age
legislators into their place I think
that's hilarious and awesome for them to
not let them come in but then again that
is the same thing as the other side
saying listen if I don't like gay people
then it's it's not the same thing
because the first person in the first
picture that I just painted that person
has transgressed by discriminating play
but you know if it's your place I'm
sorry but but like if it's my place and
I there's some people that I went to
high school with it I don't want to come
to my house yeah why can't I say you
can't come here so to that point though
so these people who say it's my business
I should be allowed to do what I want
they're bigots and then don't give them
your business should this be something
that's like legislature that's the part
to me of course you shouldn't be allowed
to discriminate against gay people but
then to me it's like gay people just
shouldn't go there like let chick-fil-a
exist and I'm not gonna eat chick-fil-a
there should just be a separate Yelp
called hates and you know a big X shows
up through the one you're going to I
mean let them do it I just think in the
end everyone's get every you know the
everyone who bans gay people from coming
you through their doors is gonna get
enough negative press as a result I
don't think more people are gonna say
you know we should do go all the way
across town because we also don't like
gay people to get our you know our
chicken sandwiches I think people are so
lazy that even if the place that you
know is in their neighborhood is run by
gay people and they hate gay people
they're just hungry and they want it
delivered so they're just going to call
yeah exactly they deliver almost
everything you want on that note in full
disclosure I should tell you that my
picture actually is on the wall at the
Abbey but that's for a whole other
reason okay